this easter weekend italy has been put
in another lockdown as coveted cases
continue to surge in europe
for the vatican the pandemic means
another empty easter
as the catholic church struggles with
falling numbers of followers
chris livesay joins us from rome chris
good morning
good morning covid restrictions are
making it challenging for pope francis
to mingle amongst the people
but for such a determined pope where
there's a vaccine
there's a way this isn't pope francis's
style
leading the way of the cross in a
deserted saint peter's square
as opposed to here at the coliseum where
he normally spends good friday
surrounded by thousands of faithful says
cbs news vatican contributor monsignor
anthony figuereto
she likes to be with the people he wants
to go to the fringes
to the poorest of the poor and the
pandemic has robbed him
of all of that he said i feel like a
prisoner
in the vatican so yesterday francis made
a break for it
paying a surprise visit to some of the
1200 homeless getting their covet
vaccine at the vatican during holy week
the pontiff paying it forward after
getting the pfizer shot earlier this
year
like so many of the newly inoculated his
first order of business
was to travel albeit to iraq
the first time for a pope where he
prayed in churches desecrated and
destroyed by isis
defying risks both to security and
public health
while francis and his entourage were
vaccinated the tens of thousands who
gathered to see him
were not something he said he prayed
about and god promised he'd take care of
them
i really believe he wanted to go to iraq
to give a message to the world
that i can break in forms in order to be
with my people especially when people
have been leaving the church in droves
amid the priest sex abuse scandal
in the past 20 years in the u.s alone
catholic church membership is down 13
according to gallup and that was before
the pandemic
lockdown churches around the world
haven't helped
the pandemic also isn't helping church
finances
specifically at the vatican museums a
source for tens of millions of dollars
in revenue now
mostly gone for cbs this morning
saturday chris lives say
rome